Good morning.
My name is Barak.
Anyone see the movie yet?
I saw it over the weekend and to cheer myself up a little bit after Saturday
afternoon,
but there's still another week to go
steal time.
I still time
morning.
Uh,
I want to talk today about my favorite part of the second discourse.
A book that never grows old.
It never fails to produce.
Last time in talking about Rousseau's account of the origins of inequality,
I focused on a famous passage in which Russo claims it was the establishment of
private property that was the true formation of civil society and the beginnings
of inequality and all of the subsequent miseries of the human race that he wants
to describe.
But in fact,
that's not really true and was so himself knows.
It's not quite true
if Roussel we're only interested in issues of class and economic inequality.
There would be very little difference between him,
uh,
and materialist theorists of society like Karl Marx,
although Mark's was in fact a very,
uh,
appreciative reader of Rousseau and gotten most of his best lines against a
capitalist society from him.
Nevertheless,
Russo understands that
even for institutions like property and civil society to be possible,
uh,
there must be huge and important developments that go on or take place even
prior to this moral and psychological transformations,
uh,
of human beings.
And it is for Roussel far more,
uh,
what we might call the moral and psychological injuries,
of inequality.
Uh,
then the material aspects of the phenomenon that is of concern to him.
Rousseau very much takes the side of the poor and the dispossessed,
uh,
but it isn't property or it isn't poverty,
rather that really route rouses Russo's anger is,
it is the attitudes and beliefs shaped by inequalities and of wealth and power.
It is rue.
So the moral psychologist,
uh,
where,
his voice truly comes out in many ways.
Russo,
uh,
like Plato finds his voice,
when discussing,
uh,
the various complexities of,
of the human soul.
So what is the chief villain,
uh,
in Rousseau's second discourse and his account of the beginnings and
development,
uh,
of inequality,
real inequality begins,
uh,
in a faculty or a disposition that is in fact,
in most editions of the book,
uh,
rendered simply by the French term because it has really untranslatable into
English.
It is Mr. Probe,
the first,
the first term I put on the board,
which is the first,
uh,
and most durable because of inequality for Russo,
I am our proper,
again,
it's an untranslatable word,
but in many ways is related to a range of psychological characteristics such as
pride,
vanity,
uh,
conceit.
Uh,
in the translation that you have are in the d,
The translation that you have.
I believe the,
the translator refers to it as egocentrism a kind of ugly,
uh,
modern,
psychologist stick a term.
I think white men probably better and more accurately,
a evocatively translated by terms like vanity and conceit or pride and more prop
prefer Roussel only arises in society and is the true cause.
He believes for our discontents and in a lengthy footnote,
uh,
that I hope you checked in a lengthy footnote,
he distinguishes Mr Prokera from a nother,
uh,
disposition that he calls and more [inaudible] ma'am,
I sort of self love how were these distinguished?
He says in that note,
we must not confuse Mr proper with love of oneself.
These are two passions,
very different by Birch,
by virtue of their nature and their effects.
Love of oneself and more does swarmed them.
Love of oneself.
It's a natural sentiment he writes,
which moves every animal to be vigilant and its own preservation in which
directed in many by reason and modified by pity produces humanity in virtue.
So there is a kind of self love he says that is at the root of our desire to
preserve ourselves,
to be strong and our self preservation and to resist the invasion or
encroachment by others.
But then he goes on to say,
Mr. Proper is,
is an entirely different kind of passion or sentiment and more proper is merely
a sentiment that is relative.
He says,
artificial and born in society,
which moves each individual to value himself more than anyone else,
which inspired in men all the evils they cause one another in which is the true
source of honor.
Listen to that last expression.
Uh,
and more appropriate,
he says is what moves every individual to value him or herself more than any
other which inspires all of the evils in society.
And he says,
is the true source of honor?
Hmm.
Both evil and honor the desire to be recognized and to steamed by others.
How can this passion of Mr Proper be responsible for these two very different
sort of competing effects?
How did it set him at a Ross?
First of all,
how did it come about?
And I suppose fundamentally and more importantly,
what can or should be done about it?
MMM.
For hubs recall and this idea of pride,
vanity,
what cobb's called vain glory.
You remember very important part of Hobbs is political and moral psychology and
Leviathan pride is seen as something natural to us.
Hubs writes,
you remember,
it is part of our natural pride is part of our natural desire to dominate a over
others.
But for Rousseau by contrast and more proper is something that could only come
about after the state of nature.
A state that Hobbs,
you remember I had called solitary,
poor,
nasty,
brutish and short after the state of nature had already begun to give way to
society.
Hubs is account,
uh,
for Russo is,
is incoherent.
Uh,
if the natural state is truly solitary,
solitary,
poor,
nasty,
brutish and short,
what would it mean?
What would it mean in such a state to feel pride or vanity that requires human
socio ability and requires the esteem of others in somehow the gays or the look
of others?
How could pride have arisen in a state of nature,
which Hobbes,
his own account is solitary.
Uh,
Russo uses hubs in a way to prove his own point that Mr Prokera vanity is not a
natural sentiment.
But as he says in that passage,
I just read a sediment that is relative and artificial could only have come into
being,
uh,
once we enter a society.
In some ways.
How bout how did that happen?
Roussel speculates about this,
and again,
this is part of is hypothetical or conjectural history.
He speculates that proper began to arise and develop.
As soon as people began to gather around a hut or a tree,
until look at one another.
As soon as we became conscious of the gaze of another,
and it is from that gaze,
from the look or gaze of another,
that this,
that the passion of vanity was born.
Listen to the way in which he speculates how this arose.
Each one he says,
began to look at the others and to want to be looked at himself.
And public esteem had a value.
The one who sang or danced the best,
the handsomest,
the strongest,
the most adroit are the most eloquent,
became the most highly regarded.
And this was the first step toward inequality.
And at the same time toward device from these first preferences were born vanity
and contempt on the one hand and shame and envy on the other.
And the fermentation caused by this new Levins eventually produced compounds
fatal to happiness and innocence.
So the rise of this passion to be seen,
to be seen,
to be best at something,
uh,
produced in many for many people.
Again,
as he puts it,
pride and vanity from some shame and envy on the part of others.
And from this,
from this fatal compound grew,
uh,
tendencies that were as he says,
fatal to our happiness and innocence.
And Rousseau I think is very much onto something here.
Uh,
and more proper is presented in,
in the passage I just read and throughout much of the second discourse in
largely negative terms,
uh,
but there is also,
it is also related to something positive in many ways for the development of
humanity and society.
The desire felt by all people once we enter society to be accorded some kind of
recognition or respect,
uh,
by those around us.
That too is a part of,
of a more proper,
the desire to be seen and recognized and respected.
The desire for recognition,
he says,
is it the root of our sense of justice
and underlying this I think is the intuition powerful.
And in many ways I think deeply true that our feelings,
beliefs,
opinions,
and attitudes be acknowledged and respected by others around us.
That we matter in some way when we feel that our opinions are slighted when
others do not recognize our worth.
We feel angry,
uh,
about this and this need for recognition,
which is part of this passion of Mr Proper is for Rousseau,
also a cornerstone of justice,
but it is also,
as he says,
at the same time,
the demand for recognition can easily become cruel and violent as we,
as we demand this from others.
Consider again just the following.
I want to read one other passage from the same part of the text.
He writes,
as soon as men had begun mutually to value one another and the idea of a steam
was formed in their minds,
each one claim to have a right to it,
each one claim to have a right to it's steam or recognition and it was no longer
possible,
he writes for anyone to be lacking it with impunity.
From this came the first duties of civility,
even amongst savages.
And from this,
every voluntary wrong became an outrage.
Every time someone was harmed or injured,
it became an outrage because along with the harm that resulted from the injury,
he says the offended party saw in it contempt for his person,
which often was more insufferable than the harm itself.
Think about the psychology that the moral psychology that Rousseau is invoking
here,
and it's talked about harm and injury.
It's not the physical aspect of the harm it that bothers him.
It is the sort of contempt that is implied or entailed in the act of injury.
Hence,
he goes on to say,
each man punished the contempt,
shown him in a matter of proportionate to the esteem in which he held himself.
Act of revenge became terrible in men,
became bloodthirsty and cruel.
It is to say Emma proper and society gave rise to the state of war.
Does this sound familiar?
I think it should.
I was trying to think of some example,
uh,
that might fit this.
And,
and one I came up with
when I was thinking about this earlier,
consider,
uh,
a story that was much in the news,
I forget if it was last spring or last summer sometime.
Uh,
the Danish cartoon controversy.
You remember that about the,
about the cartoons of the Prophet Mohammed and that outrage and protests often
violent that occurred about that to some degree.
Uh,
Russo might argue the protests were about disrespectful cartoons of the prophet,
but he would argue,
I suspect that the deeper cause seem to be that the protesters believed was
disrespect being shown to them,
to their beliefs,
to what it is they held a sacred,
in some sense,
it is their beliefs that were being disrespected.
And we're,
the cause of the protests and more Prokera as Rousseau I think himself
recognizes,
is this very volatile passion.
It contains the desire to be respected again and acknowledged that it is the,
that is at the root of Justice and virtue.
And yet at the same time,
this passion as we know is easily manipulable,
uh,
by those who wish to convince others that their basic entitlements and,
are,
are not being a,
or views are not being respected.
To some degree.
I think Russo would believe the protestors,
uh,
over those cartoons had appoint,
their views were not being respected.
Uh,
and to which you might say a and or a liberal formulation of the problem would
or response would be.
Well,
so what,
uh,
the task of government,
according to Locke or the liberal view is to ensure the security of person and
property to protect you from harm.
And of course to provide you the freedom to practice,
uh,
what religion you like a free with the consistent with the freedom of others to
do so too.
It is not the business of government to ensure that your beliefs are being
respected.
Uh,
this was clearly the view,
for example,
of the Danish newspaper editors that publish the cartoon as well as the Danish
prime minister who refuse to apologize for this on the ground.
Again,
that the government's job is not to impose a gag order on what can and cannot be
said,
uh,
on the grounds that some people might find it offensive.
Uh,
this is a respectable sort of liberal line of thought going from lock to John
Stuart Mill.
Uh,
and yet what I'm inclined to agree very much with,
with that point of view,
uh,
there is something powerful and true,
about what Rousseau has to say about it.
What about this,
this kind of issue Locky in liberal thought was addressed in many ways to people
who had experienced,
uh,
the crucible of civil war,
a century of religious conflict.
And we're looking for a way to settle a,
their religious and political differences.
Toleration,
in many ways is a liberal virtue because it requires us to distinguish between
beliefs that we may take with the utmost seriousness in private life and yet
nevertheless,
bracket them in some way once we enter the public world.
This in many ways is the peculiar liberal virtue of self restraint or a self
denial that we refuse to allow our own moral point of view too in many ways
dominate,
uh,
in the public space.
But it is one thing you might say to tolerate other views.
Uh,
and another thing to accord them respect and esteem that that seems to be
something very different from what lock,
uh,
talked about.
Uh,
to tolerate a means not to pursue it simply means not to persecute a,
to leave alone.
While I respect for something requires that we,
uh,
esteem it.
Uh,
you might ask yourself,
must we esteem and respect values and points of view,
uh,
that we do not share.
Uh,
this seems very different,
again,
from the sort of liberal understanding of toleration.
That means only a extending a acceptance to views again,
that are very different from our own.
Um,
it doesn't require us to,
as it were,
sensor self-censor,
uh,
our own views on the ground that they may be.
Our views may be in some ways disrespectful or hurtful to others.
This is a vast topic.
I've sort of used the opportunity to sort of move away from Luso so a little
bit,
but his point is I think,
uh,
the Mr proper,
the desire to be esteemed,
recognized and to have your,
uh,
your,
your values and points of view esteemed by those around you is in fact a violent
and uncontrollable passion.
Uh,
it is the passion very much like Plato's Thumos spiritedness backing in the
republic.
It makes us,
it is a passion that makes us burn with anger over perceived slights and makes,
makes us also risk our lives and endangered the lives of others to rectify what
we believe to be acts of injustice like Plato.
In many ways,
Russo wants to know whether Mr Proper is purely a negative passion or
disposition or whether like through most,
whether it can be re directed in some way to achieve social goods and social
benefits.
All of this is entailed in that short distance discussion of,
of Ama Volpara in,
in,
in the SEC,
in the second discourse,
uh,
so much of the Russo's subsequent account of civilization and its discontents
grows out of this peculiar psychological disposition and passion.
So let's talk a little bit more about civilization and its discontents.
Um,
and Woody Allen's movie Annie Hall,
you might recall a sane when he says there are two kinds of people there,
the horrible and the miserable,
the horrible,
or those who have suffered some kind of personal tragedy,
a disfigurement of some kind who are facing a terminal illness.
The miserable is everybody else.
Okay.
Roussel wants us to be miserable.
Uh,
he wants us to feel just how bad things are,
how bad we are,
how bad off we are.
The only exception to this general human misery is
as he tells us at one point,
kind of early primitive society needs to societies described by him,
not quite the state of nature to be sure I maintained a kind of middling
position between the pure state of nature in the development of modern
conditions.
He says these were the happiest and most durable societies and the best for man.
It was primitive man,
not the,
the pure savage of the state of nature where Russo finds a happy equilibrium
between our powers and our needs.
That he says is the recipe for happiness,
bringing our powers and our needs into equilibrium.
But the end of that happy state came with two inventions to discoveries,
agriculture and metallurgy.
Bless you.
With agriculture came here.
We see the division of land,
the division of property,
and the subsequent inequalities that came with it,
with metallurgy came the art of war and conquest.
With these two developments,
he tells us humanity entered a new stage,
one where laws and political institutions became necessary to adjudicate
conflicts over rights and the establishment of governments that this entailed.
Uh,
rather than bringing a piece as it would for Hobbes or Locke,
the establishment of governments had the effect simply of sanctioning the
existing inequalities that had begun to develop for Russo.
There is something deeply shocking and deeply troubling about the,
uh,
assertion that men who were once free and equal are so easily,
as it were.
Uh,
led to consent to the inequalities of property and to rule by the stronger which
government brings into being the social contract is he presents it.
And the second discourse is really a kind of swindle.
Uh,
the establishment of government is a kind of swindle that the rich and the
powerful use to control the poor and the dispossessed.
Again,
rather than instituting justice,
this compact merely legitimize his past.
Usurpations government is a con game,
uh,
that the rich play upon the poor political power simply helps to legitimize
economic inequalities.
Governments,
he tells us may operate by consent,
but the consent they are granted is based on false hoods and lies.
How else can one explain why the rich live lives that are so much freer,
so much easier,
so much more open to enjoyment than the poor?
That is Russo's real critique and real question.
And it is the establishment of government that is the last link in the chain of
Rousseau's conjectural history.
Uh,
the last and most painful in in many ways legitimation of of the inequalities
that,
uh,
has been created after our emergence from the natural condition.
Yeah.
But what again,
is most painful to Russo is the emergence of a new kind of human being that this
stage of civilization has been brought into.
This stage of civilization has brought into being Andrew.
So is the first,
I think to use that term,
uh,
so powerfully,
which became used very much in the next two centuries.
The bourgeois,
the bourgeois is Russo's invention,
uh,
in most striking about this human type for him is the necessity to appear to be
one thing where actually being something else.
Go back again to think of the way in which Plato or Socrates uses that,
a distinction between seeming and being when it,
when he talks about the just man in book,
two of the Republics,
someone who seems to be in someone who,
who is just,
it is this tension between the two that is so central to Russo's account of what
he calls the bourgeois being something and appearing to be something he says
become two different things.
And from this distinction,
there are rows,
grand ostentation,
deceptive cunning,
and all the vices that follow in their wake.
And in the pen ultimate,
uh,
paragraph of the second discourse,
Russo describes the dilemma of the bourgeois and the following way.
He says,
the savage lives within himself,
the man accustomed to the ways of society.
The bourgeois is always outside of himself and knows only how to live in the
opinions of others and as it,
and it is as it were from their judgment alone,
that he draws the sentiment of his own existence.
Think of that sentence a constant on next to the last paragraph of the book.
That in society we only live through the opinions of others through the gaze of
others,
through what others think of us.
We are constantly our own sentiment of existence.
He says,
our own,
uh,
sent sentiment of self existence comes entirely from the judgment as he puts it
of those around us.
The bourgeois,
in other words,
is someone who lives in and through the opinions,
the good opinions of others who thinks only of himself when he is with other
people and only of other people when he is in bar by himself.
Such a person is duplicitous,
hypocritical and false.
This is why this is the true,
uh,
you might say discontent of civilization.
This is,
this is what our perpetual restlessness and reflectiveness,
uh,
have made of us goated on perpetually by em or proper.
It is.
This is the particular misery that civilization has bequeathed.
Just so the question at the end of the book is what to do about this and here,
uh,
in many ways,
one has to say the second discourse false short,
uh,
the book know that the essay,
the book
ends on a note of,
of utmost despair.
Uh,
it offers no positive answer to cure the problem of civilization,
but only hints at best a at two possible solutions.
One is suggested you,
you will recall by the letter to the city of Geneva,
which in a sense prefaces the book,
uh,
perhaps the closest approximation to the early state of primitive society.
Lauded by Rousseau I the small isolated rural republics like,
like Geneva in his own way,
where a kind of simple patriotism and love of country have not been completely
overwhelmed by the agitations of Mr Pro bar only.
He says in a well tempered democracy like Geneva,
is it possible for citizens still to enjoy some of the equality of the natural
man democracy for him?
This kind of simple rural democracy like that of Geneva is the social condition
that most closely approximates the equality of the state of nature.
And that of course is a theme that Roussel we'll take up powerfully,
uh,
in his book the social contract.
But Rizzo offers another hint,
uh,
to,
to the solution of the problem of civilization,
what to do about it.
How can we restore happiness and,
uh,
in,
in the midst of society,
the second discourse leaves us to believe that all society is a state of bondage
and alienation from nature.
From our true being.
We,
we have our true humanity that he describes in a state of nature,
state of Pitt,
these for pity and compassion and the like.
And the answer to the problem of society is in many ways to return to the root
of society.
And this route of society is the,
not just the need for self preservation,
but a kind of primordial as he calls it in that passage I read a minute ago,
sentiment of existence,
the sentiment of our own existence by giving oneself over to this feeling of
existence without a thought for the future,
without care or fear,
the individual somehow psychologically returns to the natural state.
Only a very few people,
Rousseau writes,
he being one of them.
Of course,
only a very few people are capable of finding their way back to nature.
Uh,
the type of human being who can find their way back to the sort of pure
sentiment of existence is not going to be a philosopher,
is not going to be a person of high order reflection like Socrates,
but will more likely be an artist or a poet.
A,
he has one of those rare,
uh,
aristocrats of nature,
you might say.
Um,
his claim to special to superiority is not based on a higher understanding,
but it's superior sensitivity,
uh,
less on wisdom then on compassion.
Um,
Rousseau believed himself to be one of these people.
Uh,
maybe you also are one of them.
Yes.
But it requires you in some way to distance yourself severely and
psychologically from all of the possibilities of society to return inward.
And it was that inward journey that Rousseau took and that he writes about so
powerfully in his confessions and his final book,
the reveries where you find the Roussel founder of the romantic disposition that
you get again.
And writers in America like Thoreau and others who look inward and returned to
nature in some way,
their natural self,
uh,
as opposed to society.
But the second discourse leave leaves us to be sure with a paradox.
Uh,
the progress of civilization is responsible for all of our miseries.
Yes,
it is society's fault.
It's not your fault.
It's society's he wants to tell us.
And yet he also leaves us with no real apparent way out.
He denies that we can as a practical solution,
uh,
return to simpler,
more natural forms of political association.
But how then do we resolve the problem of,
uh,
that he leaves us with?
And his answer to it is political answer to it is most famous political answer
to it is contained in his book.
Yes,
called the social contract.
Do contract sociale published in 1762,
seven years after the second discourse here.
He attempts to give one such answer and I mentioned one such answer because it
is not his only or final answer,
but one such answer to the problems of inequality.
And the uh,
the again,
the injuries of,
of,
of uh,
of ammo pro pro,
uh,
social contract begins with one of the most famous sentences,
in all of the history of political philosophy.
Man is born free and is everywhere in chains.
Always begin your essays with a good,
strong sentence like that.
Rousseau knew this,
he knew something about how to write.
The phrase is seems to be perfectly in keeping with the second discourse in the
state of nature.
We are born free,
equal and independent.
Only in society do we become weak,
dependent and enslaved.
It is what follows after that sentence in a way that is the shocker.
How did this take?
How did this change take place?
Roussel asks,
I do not know what can render it legitimate.
I believe I can answer this question.
What can render it legitimate?
And by the Itch I take it,
he means the chains is in.
This stays man is born free and just everywhere in Shane's.
And the second discourse here at attempted to completely delegitimize the bonds
of society saying how the social contract and the creation of government was.
It was nothing but,
but in many ways a sophisticated Swindell.
Now in the social contract,
he asks the question,
what can give these chains or bonds moral legitimacy?
He says,
I believe I can answer that as Rousseau simply undergone a massive change of
heart in the seven years between these two books.
Uh,
I don't think so.
but I think these are,
this is part of his,
one of his answers to this fundamental question.
But before going into the details of this,
let's consider some of the differences between these two very powerful books,
right?
Uh,
the second discourse,
the discourse on inequality presents itself as a hypothetical or conjectural
history of human development from the state of nature to the civil condition.
It is written in a vivid language is why it is always,
uh,
is often considered one of Rousseau's most powerful pieces of writing a vivid
language drawing on in many ways by the biological sciences of his day and newly
discovered knowledge of animal species like a rang of tangs and other kinds of
anthropological investigations of the Caribs and North American peoples.
A very vivid,
uh,
work.
The social contract by contrast is written a dry,
uh,
even the kind of bloodless language of a lawyer.
Uh,
it is very much written in the genre of a legal document.
Its subtitle is the principles of political right.
Uh,
it is a work of considerable philosophical abstraction,
uh,
who's leading concepts are abstractions,
like the social contract,
the general will.
And the so on the book he tells us in his short preface was originally part of a
longer investigation of politics which has since been,
which he says has since been lost.
Also the social contract presents itself in many ways as a utopia in ideal city
in some respects and answer to the Koan Lippolis of Plato's Republic and get
this is also now.
This seems to be not quite true.
The work begins even before the famous sentence about man being born free.
The work is prefaced with a statement that could have come directly out of
Machiavelli's Prince taking men as they are and laws as they might be.
Rousseau says,
I will try in this inquiry to bring together what right permits with what
interest prescribes taking men as they are.
You remember the 15th chapter of the Prince?
Let us look at the effectual truth of things,
not what is imagined to be but but the way people actually are.
Let us take men as they are.
Rousseau says following Machiavelli,
he will not begin.
He tells us by making any heroic assumptions about human nature,
no metaphysical flights of fancy but rather stay on the low,
uh,
but solid ground of recognized fact.
What does he mean by this and what are these facts of human nature men as they
are,
he says that Rousseau claims to describe,
uh,
in,
in the social contract.
And here we get to the basic premise of the book.
Okay.
The basic premise I think from which the entire social contract unfolds is the
claim that man is born free.
All subsequent relations of hierarchy,
obligation and authority are the result.
Not Nature,
but if agreement or convention society and the moral ties that constituted our
conventional,
you might say by agreement or all the way down.
There is nothing natural about any of the,
uh,
social contract.
And from this basis of man as a free agent that we are born free Russo attempt
to work out a system of justice.
The principles of political right,
again,
as the subtitle suggests that are appropriate to human beings,
conceived as free agents,
responsible to themselves alone.
But how do you do that?
How can you do that?
Russo's political philosophy begins,
at least he believes,
I think with the realistic or even empirical assumption that each individual has
a deep rooted interest in securing the conditions of their own liberty.
Uh,
the state of nature and the social contract presuppose individuals who are in
competition with others and each attempting as it were to secure the conditions
for their own liberty.
He does not presuppose altruism on the part of any human being or any other kind
of self.
Other regarding characteristics,
what I call a moment ago,
heroic assumptions.
He doesn't make the assumption that we are act for the interests of others.
We are selfishly concerned with our own freedom and the best means of preserving
it and protecting us.
Each of us has a desire to preserve his or own freedom and this,
that social order will be rational or just that allows us to preserve that
freedom.
The problem of course,
is that in the state of nature,
the desire to preserve my freedom comes into conflict with the selfish desire of
everybody else to preserve their freedom.
The state of nature quickly becomes a state of war based on conflicting desires.
And con conflicting again means of,
of,
of liberty preservation.
So how do we preserve our liberty without lapsing into anarchy?
Uh,
that is the state of war.
This is the question that the social contract sets out to answer and to which
his formulation is famous formulation of what he calls the general will is the
solution.
Uh,
I'm going to end on that note today and Wednesday we'll,
I want to talk about the general will and how Russo sees it as a sort of
collective answer to the problem of the securing of individual liberty.
So meditate on that if you like for the next day.